WAY HE PLAYED IN.
CERTAINLY GOING TO SAVE.
REBOUND LOOSE IN FRONT.
SCORES!
MICHAEL RASMUSSEN OPENS THE
SCORI GOT
TURNED AROUND.
ZUB AHEAD TO GAUDETTE.
BANKS IT AHEADE.
>> Gord: MOM AND DAD GET I ILAR.
NOW PLAYED BACK.
IN, FIRES.
THATAT OPEN AND A LITTLE ZONE.
SEIDER GOOD BACK.
A TALENTED
PLAYER, GORD.
REALLY WELL LIKED IENTRY.
ONE-TIMER.
NORRIS DIDN'T SHOOT SHOTS ON GOR
OF OTTAWIN.
DYLAN LARKIN.
BANKS IT BACK.
JOSEPH BROUGHT A LOT TO THE
TABLE IN HIS EARLY DAYS W
>> HEEL
DROPS IT BACK FOR THE TRAILER
ZUB.
THAT'S KNOCKED ONG THE BOARDS.
WINS THE BATTLE WITH HIGH GETTI
THE FRONT OF THE NET.
TH
FORMENTON.
UP AHEAD FOR
PLAYS IT BACK IN DEEP FOR IT BA
TO THE DETROIT ZONE.IN THIS GAM.
>> Jamie: FORSBERG WITH A SOLID
HAT TRICK PERFORMANCE IN DETROIT
ON F F ASSIST TONIGHT, TODAY
RATHER.
>> Jamie: I HAVE SAID IT A FEW
NOT JUST THE NHL ONE.
DYLAN LARKIN.
HRONEK -- SORRY, THAT'S NOT A
BACKHAND SAUCER.
ZADINA.
VRANA BACK TO
ZAITSEV PLAYS IT AROUND.
KNOCKEDEDSEASON.
ZAITSEV JUST THROWS IT 200 FEET.